hey wassup guys my name is Archana and
today we're going to be starting a new
series new mini series on serialization
so this is kind of the idea for this
came from the game programming series
because this is actually going to be
required for the game programming series
so everyone is following along with that
series I do encourage that you watch
this but this is also going to be
applicable to everything which is why
I'm kind of making this as like a
standalone series because what I'm going
to do and what I'm going to teach you in
this series will be applicable to pretty
much anything right and in fact it's
even going to be able to go to Sparky to
some extent because this party engine is
going to be using a similar system as to
what I'm going to basically implement
here but anyway all that aside it should
be fun and we're going to be little and
am I going to be learning all about
civilization which is always a great
topic so first of all what is
civilization because I'm sure that a lot
of you have heard it being mentioned
from time to time and you've heard it
before and you kind of maybe gotten a
bit scared of it and you've kind of just
heard it in passing and you've been like
I don't know what that is I don't really
care so what is realization so
civilization is actually very simple
it's actually very broad as well all it
really means is it's basically the
process of converting an object into a
stream of bytes okay so by object I
don't mean literally like a Java object
or something like that it can really
mean anything so which is why the
definition as I mentioned is extremely
broad right all it means is that you've
got all this all this information
essentially so for example a good
example would be like an entity right an
entity in your game might have something
like if I'm just gonna draw stuff for
you guys here an entity in your game
might have properties such as a name you
know the position I don't know
information about the inventory they
contained anything like that rice here's
the handwriting by the way she's gonna
have to deal with it hmm it's hard to
write on this very old and inferior
tablet anyway you might have all this
dadah here and this is like information
that is relatives relevant to you in the
game right once it's in memory in your
application in your game you're
constantly using and it's constantly
important to the way that the game kind
of functions and it's something that you
kind of need right but a civilization is
essentially the process of taking all
that and converting it into basically a
byte array for all intents and purposes
converting it into a stream advice okay
and you might be like why am I going to
be converting this information into a
stream of bytes you know what use does
that have and it has a lot of uses okay
the two primary uses we're going to be
looking at for this series is going to
be to write it out into a file okay and
also to essentially write it out into
the network okay so those are the two
situations we're going to be dealing
with okay so by file the best example of
this is like a safe game right you want
to basically say about the state of your
game into a file so that you can then
close the game and then at a later time
the player can open the game and
essentially deserialize that file and
get all of that state back into memory
so that they can continue where they
left off okay that's the usage of a file
that's the best way to describe it okay
another very very common thing so like
save games again are one example but
you've also got stuff like essentially
assets for the game okay so like for
example a lot of games have essentially
like a level editor and you might use it
you you you might create a tool for your
engine that actually helps you design
the levels and whatnot and then mostly
you would basically convert all that
data that you make in that level editor
into like a form at a certain file right
and then at runtime when the game starts
it loads that level and you know it
needs a way to do that and that's where
sterilization comes in as well because
that's what example files right so
assets really and really any custom
format that you might have like a car
to model format or a custom texture
format really anything right will
basically need some form sort of
sterilization because obviously that
will be stored on disk as a binary file
for example this is concerning binary
files we'll get into that later as well
and it needs a way to basically
interpret that and convert that into
into memory as required okay so that's
the idea of the file the network is a
bit different essentially what I mean
with that is stuff like multiplayer and
essentially essentially stuff like
packets okay so we want to be able to
send packets of data over the network
and packets and packets are just like a
bunch of bytes that you want to send
over the network so the game programming
series of course is beginning its
multiplayer journey right now so if you
missed the first kind of introduction to
multiplayer video I would encourage you
to go and watch that if you're
interested in that series but basically
we are starting multiplayer in game
programming and because of that we need
a way to send data from computer to
computer okay and that's where the
relation comes in because we need to be
able to basically format all of our data
into a format that we can just send over
the network and obviously it needs to be
efficient and and fast as well as you
know easy to use and whatnot and we need
a special format for that so we'll get
into like the network side of things a
bit more as we go on with this series
and I will probably touch a bit on that
but we're like just for now we're going
to be focusing on the file aspect of
sterilization just because it's a lot
easier to test it doesn't require
anything pretty much writing out our
resulting byte array into a file for
example and being able to read and write
that is actually much easier than having
to set up a bunch of network protocols
to deal with us not to mention two
computers potentially or two instances
of an application to be able to send a
receive data so we're going to be
focusing on the file thing with a format
that I'm going to design here is going
to be the same so the same stuff that we
send over the network will be written to
a file as well and whatnot so they'll
they will be into it they will be
interchangeable and they will be
identical for this series okay so anyway
that is the idea so
a transmission of data both to a file
and over the network is essentially the
concept of sort of sterilization okay I
hope that makes sense if it doesn't you
can leave a comment below and I'll try
and reply to a lot of these but I think
that explains it pretty well
okay so mmm let's get started so today
we're going to be talking about the
format and how it's going to work and
I'm also going to touch a bit on
definitions of certain words I mentioned
probably and this is going to serve as
like an introductory video but also like
a planning kind of video of what this is
going to look like and then next time
we'll kind of continue on to probably
learning how we can actually do stuff
like the conversion of this stuff into
bytes and back and we'll kind of just go
on from there so first of all I have to
mention that I'm going to be writing the
actual code for this theorization
library that we're going to be making
here in Java now the reason I'm doing it
in Java and a lot of you might be
surprised and or angry but the reason
I'm doing it in Java and the only reason
I'm doing it in Java is because of the
game programming series if because this
is basically going to I'm going to
design this in such a way that the game
programming series can simply kind of
load that library that we make here and
use it and that's it so I'm not going to
be doing what I did with the events
system where I'm going to basically copy
and paste everything into the code now
I'm actually going to be designing it as
a pure library okay so that comes to my
second question or my your second
question is Java a good thing to use for
this is it going to be easy in Java the
answer is no this is actually going to
be quite difficult to do in Java because
Java has very few features let's just
say when it comes to stuff like direct
memory access which is a problem because
civilization as you can probably tell is
all about bytes and all about memory
access and all about getting getting
stuff from and to memory okay because
Java has problems with that as well as
there are a lot of things that I noticed
while writing this relation form and
Java that are just going to be kind of
annoying too right okay and you and I'll
kind of point them out one
they come up but the point is that Java
is not a great language for this kind of
stuff because admittedly this is quite
low level and this is kind of the stuff
that a language like C++ would
absolutely excel at not to mention it
would be very much more efficient and
this civilization format that I'm
actually going to write here is actually
a port of the sparkly civilization
format which isn't actually integrated
into Sparky yet but it's more or less a
standalone library that I've just
written in my spare time and it's long
being her or anything yet but this is
almost like a backboard from that
syphilis law stuff so yes I have to
change a lot of things because the way
job is written but but it has to be done
because the game programming series and
I'm not going to like I don't know a lot
of you guys might be like you could
still just write it and say plus blossom
and pass it into Java by J&I or
something and that's not gonna happen
because that's going to require a lot of
extra work just because if just because
of um just because of many things okay
so anyway that's the idea this is going
to be run in Java so I might do a Sybil
small version of this later if you guys
are interested because I'm going to have
to do it anyway for Sparky but for now
we're using Java and that's just that oh
that's the end of that ok cool so let's
talk about the let's talk about a few
terms here so binary ok binary and text
these are two ways that you can store
files essentially but actually that's
probably about it I can't think of any
other ways you can store files you can
still files as binary data you can store
files as text so text might be something
like a XML file okay so in fact I happen
to have one open here right now so this
is like an example of this is actually
just something I've already in sublime
text not even relevant point is X amount
this is this is an XML for example this
is actually in case you guys are
interested some reason this is part of
the sake CLR generator but essentially
this is this is what would be what you
would call a text file format because it
is as you can see written in plain text
and there's nothing
there's really nothing here that is
essentially binary right it's just it's
a bunch of characters okay it's plain
text the advantages of these kind of
formats are very simple they are
readable by humans very easily and
modifiable by few fake humans really
easily if I wanted to change this or I
wanted to add let's just say I wanted to
add another type for what I'm missing
here I wanted to add another type for
like short or something and I want to do
something like that you can see I can
quickly do that stuff and there's no
problem whatsoever okay so that's kind
of the way that that works it's pretty
it's pretty simple text file formats are
always good for stuff like property
files or things that you want people to
be able to add but you don't necessarily
want them to be in the GUI so stuff like
configuration files are generally a good
way to go and obviously these have their
advantages and disadvantages the quick
advantages of this as I just mentioned
were human readability and reliability I
guess but the disadvantages are the fact
that is just going to be less efficient
and slow up because if you want to
basically load and process this in your
application it means that you have to
basically do a lot of strength parsing
which means that you have to do stuff
like splitting strings and like looking
for certain key words and it's just it's
it's a bit of a mess and it's very
inefficient compared to something like
binary before a retic talked about in a
minute so what does the binary file look
like well I'm glad you asked because I
don't actually have any open right now
let's see if I can find something you
know what let's just open this mp4 file
that's binary so this is what binary
files look like they look like binary
okay so this is obviously hexadecimal
but it's just a it's just a
representation of the actual binary data
that is in this file because it's much
easier to read hex than binary it's much
less the birthrate hex and binary
because obviously we advise into less
characters but essentially each every
two digits is a byte okay because that's
the way that works because one digit can
store anywhere between 0 and 15 and then
sorry yes they're on 15 and then that
obviously two of them so that's four
bits and this is four bits and you get a
bite being too acid there's no
characters so that being said this is
yeah again it's a binary file you have
no idea what it says you have no idea
how it works it's just a bunch of
numbers for all you care right but the
point is that this is obviously much
quicker for the computer to read for a
few reasons
okay and it's really just up to you and
up to how the binary format is
structured because what happens is that
when you read this instead of reading in
strings and then having to essentially
convert those things you read into
strings and then having to do multiple
string operations to extract the data
you want the data is really just
available for you straight away okay so
you might be like I know that for
example this is a video file as an mp4
file you might know that for example in
this mp4 file format which I don't know
how that works right now so I'm not
going to none of this none of what I'm
going to say is true but let's just say
that you know that the I don't know like
the sixteenth flight or whatever has a
certain thing let's just say the line
six for example this is the start of the
name of the mp4 file for example you
might be like okay so the length of the
thing we're at 7-7 bytes long and then
like this is it right it's like the name
of the thing so what happens is if you
want to know what the name of the mp4
file is for example you'll be like oh I
know exactly what to rate I just need to
know the offset which I do because I
know how the format works and then I
just load this into memory and that's it
I'm done
okay so what basically what I'm trying
to say I know that this is probably
sounding pretty complicated but what I'm
trying to say is that for most cases yes
the what you want to actually load into
your memory and what you see here is
pretty much the same so if I want to
load this data into memory all I have to
do is read it okay and that's it I don't
have to do any kind of string passing
all I say is that I'm going to basically
allocate a new array I'm going to read
in these bytes and that's it it is in my
memory now okay
and of course you don't even have to
bring it into memory you can do other
things like memory mapping which is way
out of scope here but that's the basic
idea okay so I don't want to complicate
you guys too much but that's the way
that it works all right so we're going
to be obviously creating a binary format
because there's no reason to create a
text format it's going to be sent
remember the primary purpose that this
is the multiplayer thing so we're going
to be sending it to and from computers
and there's no reason for us to use text
for that because if we do use text for
that it means that we have to format our
string with our data in a special way
unlike the computer one for example and
then computer 2 has to receive a stream
of bytes obviously cuz you can't send
text of a network this will have to
receive that string of bytes converted
to a text and then pass the text to get
the data out it's just very very weird I
hope you guys know what I mean by the
way I might make another video covering
the details with this I'm kind of trying
to rush through this that's the idea so
that being said already like 15 minutes
so so that being said binary is going to
be the way to go all right so the format
when we come to binary ok we need to
have some kind of format
so usually format wise which will
actually talk about next time because
we're way out of time this was more or
less an introduction video and I keep
drawing random things yeah we need to
design some kind of format this is our
goal right now we need to we need to
design a format which can change
contains all of the data we need in a
way that can be read quickly and also in
a way that can be somewhat easy to
implement ok so we might want to do for
example when we have our entity yeah we
need to obviously be like hey I want to
write out the name of the entity the x
and y the entity and the inventory
contents or whatever the entity into
this file but then remember writing into
a file is easy you might just be like
take the bytes of name write it take the
bicep X&Y write it and then that you're
done right but the problem is how do you
read that back
how do you deserialize it so how do you
say that okay I've opened up a file and
now I want to set name and x and y equal
to the actual data that I wrote that I
wrote out into that file right how do
you how do you retrieve that in order to
retrieve this stuff from that file that
you sterilized
you need to know information about it
such as what you're trying to get so you
might be like let's open up the entity
section of the file let's retrieve the
name so maybe you'll have a key called
name and it will actually contain the
string that is the name so that you can
set that equal to that all right same
with X Y you might look and you might be
like okay look for an entity object in
our in our civilization format and then
extract its X&Y
which might be like floats or something
or integers right we need a way to be
able to do that we need a way to be able
to create files that are both easy to
save and quick to kind of save out data
as well as not taking up too much space
right because space matters especially
for network transmission because the
more bytes we have the longer it's going
to take them it's going to take to send
that stuff that stuff and then we also
need to be able to efficiently be able
to be like hey I want to read a certain
property a certain value inside that's
the way they can format and retrieve it
back into my entity object okay so that
is going to require quite an efficient
format quite quite a cleverly designed
format that um that is going to be able
to do this in a good way okay so we're
going to be talking all about that next
time I'm going to outline the format
next time and we're going to get this
party started
so if you guys enjoyed this video please
hit the like button also if you want to
support me making videos such as this
one the best way to do that is to head
on over onto patreon.com forward slash
the Cherno there is a link in the
description but here is the webpage and
then you can become a patron by giving a
certain amount per month and of course
you do get rewarded for that so if you
pledge five dollars or more per month
you get access to the entire source code
of game programming by get
the source code to this is actually
going to be released for free on github
so don't worry about that
but it's just a good way to support me
and I'm sure that I have more time to
make videos such as these also I did
make a slack channel for those of you
who are not aware still it's slack if
you go to slacked off the chair comm you
will be greeted with a join the churner
kind of thing right basically what a
slash channel is is it's like a it's
just like a chat kind of community
situation so it's like a it's like a
community you can join and it's
essentially called a team right but
basically it just means that you can
join like a channel like a chat channel
and there's as much people talking about
stuff over there in fact I might show
you guys right now whoops all right not
sure if I've even got the desktop app
installed but once once you register for
that you can actually head over to the
Cherno dot slash calm which I can
definitely show you guys I have to log
in and everything okay you're gonna have
to trust me on this just follow the link
in the description and basically they'll
label all of you guys to talk to each
other in real time okay anyway thanks
for watching guys I'll see you guys next
time goodbye